Brian Cashman the Yankees senior vice
president general manager joining us in
Seaton just got busted by Brian Cashman
yes you guys are the worst ever Brian
came in and realized that you'd skipped
Allegiance hear from you you'd switch
from the Yankees to the Red Sox I think
that these are horrible inaccuracies
they and fallacies that you guys
continue to what did you call him Brian
it's not see it's not Satan it's Satan
Wow I think there's a lot of people who
think that could you if you weren't a
Yankee employee could you ever root for
the Red Sox like when you're done with
this job could you ever see yourself
being at least appreciating what you see
with the Red Sox going to a red sock
game as a fan I grew up a Dodger fan you
know I'm from Kentucky and I was a huge
Dodger fan which made me a Yankee hater
as a kid and you know growing up but you
know so but you know I've been bought
and paid for
who's your favorite player growing up
Ron Cey really yeah the penguin yeah
yeah that was a great infield any little
short guy that they had some pop and
stuff Gio Morgan because Cincinnati was
about 81 miles north of me in Lexington
Kentucky and so you know but back then
the Dodgers and the Reds were in the
same division everybody it was Reds
territory so I went the opposite way and
picked their rival the Dodgers and stuff
and so I girls he died of Reds fan in
Cincinnati so Big Red Machine that's
pretty good since now yeah I did I was
pretty lucky but back then I knew that
that bench and Perez and Morgan and
rosewood would be there the next year
but you know if the Reds were if that
team was today you couldn't keep that
you couldn't afford that team now they
were amazing they really were I would
still remember Johnny Bench in the grand
slam against my Dodgers leading the game
Riverfront Stadium and you know going
home and that long drive angry upset you
know that's all the above so we're you
Steve Garvey you know I mean at the
build one field we had that infield for
eight years which was a think of record
so as Garvey Lopes Russell say I
actually got to be batboy for the
Dodgers and spring training so Tommy
Lasorda to this day takes credit for my
start in baseball and so I was I was a
crazy Dodger fan
and you know but you know baseball fan
I'll admit but then got the internship
with the Yankees and you know the next
you know I was alright Dodgers my
national team but did you think about
working for the did you try to work for
the Dodgers
it you know I actually had an
opportunity you know previous ownerships
and stuff to leave the Yankees to go to
the Dodgers and do the same job and and
you know I stayed you know and I stayed
at loyalty because George Steiner gave
me the opportunity as an intern and and
I worked my way up the ladder and the
only reason I am whatever I am is
because of him and giving me the
opportunity you know he offered me the
GM job which I wasn't expecting I was
never trying to be I was eight assistant
GM for six years I've been with the
Yankees since 86
before 98 hit and and you know he you
know he took a liking to me and and you
know I guess guided me I was a graduate
of George Stanford University in the end
and add a loyalty I stayed so you're
probably what's the proudest moment of
being a GM of the Yankees delivering a
World Championship I mean the best time
people ask what that first one any of
them you know the bottom line is you
know I get that question what's what's
the best part of being the GM in the
Yankees you say winning and what's the
worst part it's losing its this the
truth I mean when you're when things
aren't going the way you want you know
it's tough and and when things are you
know come to completion when you have a
game plan and execute it and I've got
five World Series titles for as GM one
is as assistant GM under Bob Watson I
mean it's just nothing like it and that
Canyon of Heroes and everything comes
with it but you know in the front office
it doesn't last long
because you know next you know you're
off on a flight to the GM meetings and
the Winter Meetings and you're trying to
either put two came together keep it
together or make it better and everybody
else is getting better at the same time
so it's it's just that constant
challenge the reaction to fans when
you're not going doing well what do they
say to you I don't know if they say it
to me social media is pretty ugly you
know I can you know are you on social
media no no no but I certainly see you
know you know what people tell you that
you actually know the thing that I get a
lot which you know they're being really
nice but it's like a backhanded slap
like I don't care what it what everybody
says I think I'm doing a great job I get
that so
that it's it's my posting the picture
sign the autograph or whatever and like
man I don't care what anybody says I
think you're - everybody's saying I
think they're doing a great job so right
away you know what's everybody's saying
you know so you know the Yankee GM job
is interesting because when you win it's
because you got the money and when you
lose you how can you mess up with all
that money and but you know if it was
that easy the Yankees have a hundred
championship how important is this
because well viddy go that and and I
said this you could be the GM of the
year with with what how I mean you made
some risky moves you brought some kids
up it sort of worked out I don't know if
it's worked out better than you thought
but you don't you're never gonna get the
credit you're you're going to get
criticized but I don't know if you will
ever get the credit and we were talking
about this last week I said you're
developing you're a Hall of Fame general
manager I mean you're getting into you
know that rarefied air Bob Howsam was
there Pat Gillick you know some great
great front office people and I'm not
saying it because you hear because they
said it last week is that enough for you
you don't have to be recognized patted
on the back you probably get have your
critics other GM's hey you got money you
got a payroll so how do you respond to
that you know I I was conditioned in the
george steinbrenner world this wasn't
about being a graduate of George
stammering University and the way he ran
things no one was allowed you know to
even have and you go other than himself
we don't know for everybody so anytime
it started anybody you know even when
you know Joe Torre is great and a
hall-of-famer that he is you know George
started to resent over time all the
accolades coming his way and and so it
was almost like the the smart play was
to learn and condition yourself to if
things go great you through the BK's
everywhere else and deflect anything
that might come your way because if if
too much comes your way then you're now
putting yourself in a spotlight to not
last very long but did that lead to the
breakup of torreón Steinbrenner
ultimately I think so he got I
definitely I was I'm not saying Joe had
an ego I you know as much as I think
George yeah I think I think there was
like anything else it's there's only the
boss was you know the
greatest of all time at what he did and
how he did it and what he built and how
he added to it and but again you know he
he was an owner and everybody else was
the employee and everybody had this stay
in their lanes and be in their places
and if anybody became bigger than you
know maybe him or the brand and you know
then there was gonna be a rectifying
situation eventually would occur and I
think that obviously in the end because
every contract Tory negotiated with
Steinbrenner was direct from Joe and
George so many of the deals worked out
and the last one didn't and you know he
was offered a one-year deal by the boss
and it didn't work out and you know and
but I think it was one of those
situations I think Joe described even to
this day is I don't think anybody at
that time you had to say goodbye you
know so but yeah I do think that there
isn't jealousy and all those stuff and I
think that's that's not abnormal for
when you're an alpha dog and you're you
know you know the boss is a
hall-of-famer even though he's not there
yet I mean he's a hall-of-famer you got
a Joe a hall-of-famer that you know
alpha dogs and eventually something
gives what did you think of Larry Larry
David in with the Seinfeld impersonation
of sniper Anna I mean he had actually
some coaching from behind the scenes we
had a we had somebody who was on staff
at the time apparently was giving you
know some behind-the-scenes better no
this no no but I do remember I do
remember he had a chance to play himself
on that show before it was the greatest
hit common history and I remember the
fax coming through to my office I
delivered over to legal counsel and it
was you know a suggestion of him here's
a show here's what we're gonna do and
you can play yourself and and he turned
it down and then later on I'm sure he
was like wow yeah because I think grew
into something spectacular and so you
know I get you know I get every now and
then still to this day you know you know
what's the the bald guy with the glasses
escapes my name on the show you know the
short guy George Costanza Costanza I
like thing I get the Costanza stuff
every now and then because he was the
traveling secretary the assistant to the
traveling secretary so I've heard that
over the years enough now do you do you
think that's based on you know no no no
I wasn't I wasn't
me other people think it's based off you
know but you know they just throw it at
me and you know have fun with it so when
we come back can you say okay when we
come back I want to know if George
Steinbrenner was still running the
Yankees what would he have done with Tim
Tebow and I want your favorite George
Steinbrenner story that you'll tell your
grandkids will come back with Brian
Cashman you you're gonna I give you a
little bit of time here though yeah
you'll be good sure all right we'll be
back with Brian Cashman dodger lover
right after this Brian Cashman the
Yankees senior vice president general
manager joining us in studio got some
young talent there they won five in a
row two games back and no longer a
feel-good story they're actual
contenders here when we went to break I
teased a couple things your favorite
Steinbrenner story that you'll tell your
grandkids but let me start with Tebow
the Mets signed Tebow for a minor-league
deal hundred thousand dollars how
serious were the Yankees about Tim Tebow
you know we sent two Scouts and we
evaluated that you made a decision not
to pursue it you know so you know we
didn't when he follow up on him but got
a lot of respect for the fact he's a
great athlete clearly and you know he's
got a dream and it's hard you know in
this day and age with all the coverage
you know and stuff it's hard to put
yourself out there to pursue a dream so
I got great respect for what he's doing
and you know I wish him the best of luck
you know I did I really focused more on
you know what I don't know if he's gonna
get there or not but I know it when he
was at Florida and his reputation of
work ethic and character is off the
charts so he's someone that you want to
surround all your people with you know
you know so that type of energy and
effort rubs off you know you want us you
know so I thought about it a little bit
that way but I wish him the best of luck
he's a he's obviously you know pursuing
a dream and and that's what the others
country is all about was George
Steinbrenner have had you saw him maybe
you know I never thought about it until
you brought it up but but George was
quite he was a big the biggest showman
of all and anything and everything that
was you know an attention grabber and
get her and you know he might have you
know I don't know he might you know
especially if he had a relationship with
him you know because George was such a
big college football fan that he
probably would have known Tim rally
would have met him at various you know
functions in the worid banquets
and charity events and if he had a
relationship with him yeah he might have
you know it said I don't care what
anybody says this is what you're doing
and this is what we're gonna do and he
would have mapped out a strategy and and
you know it's possible I don't know you
know I never thought about it how many
times you think you were almost fired
you know there was quite a few times
that you know you know I jean-michel was
one of my mentors and he taught me to do
underrated in Yankee history of what he
did in I don't know I mean I think
pretty much an argue if you get feels
like nationally well no yeah I'm sure
Yankee fans but I always felt that stick
was so underrated yeah he felt like
national he was an amazing you know
advisor for the boss did everything from
managed play coach general manage you
know he did it all super scout and so
but anyways working under him as the
assistant GM you know for as long as I
did I I saw him go you know I got a
chance to because I worked for so many
general managers so with so many
managers because it was a revolving door
because you know it was an intense
situation and and he was as tough as
they come to work for and you know
jean-michel showed me that you just got
to stand your ground and he you know he
said the boss wants that you know but I
think he was so intimidating most people
wouldn't they would just you know kind
of execute whatever he wanted but gee
Michael knocked heads with him and then
when I felt it was appropriate I'd do
the same thing and you just didn't know
how it would react and you ever get
fired for a half hour no he would he but
but you know he never actually you know
uttered any of those words but but the
only he would ever do is when he wanted
to do something so it was 98 you wanted
me to trade for Randy Johnson from
Seattle he wants you know Cleveland was
our big rival that particular year is my
first year Jim and he's like you better
do this you've been he's pressuring the
hell out of me to trade for Randy
Johnson but our team was so good I was
worried that Randy I had known Randy Lou
Pinella being a former manager of ours
and I had worked with him idle was asked
blue when he's managed in Seattle every
time they'd go on the East Coast Swing
you know Randy was supposed to pitch
against us and then it would turn out
they'd reshuffle the rotation he pitched
the last game and depending where the
first came in Baltimore and he'd miss us
so I thought it happened year after year
and I finally I salute hey what's going
on with that he said he doesn't like the
pitch at Yankee Stadium
so right
I was like I'm gonna trade for this guy
doesn't wanna pitch in New York in
Yankee Stadium and you know so at the
end of the day I chose not to and he he
would take the position of you better be
right and and and he wound up going to
Houston you know and they got and he was
amazing
and yeah I got knocked out in the first
round and you know so we didn't have to
deal with him with the Indians and you
know the rest was history we went on and
won the World Series that year but the
position Jorge would take would be if I
was adversarial against something he
wanted I would say jean-michel tell me
this all right I'll do that if there's
what you want I'm gonna make sure
everybody knows this is what you want
yeah but then he became a Yankee in 105
yes yeah yeah what happened well we were
desperate and at the end of it and at
the end of the day you know that 98 I
mean again you have to evaluate your
your team chemistry or anything else the
98 team had something that was so unique
and special that you know you didn't
want to mess with that clubhouse too
easily and and I mean it didn't really
seem to have a need where the 2005 team
did so so it was just completely
different circumstances so we were
thinking about this when we knew we were
gonna have y'all an employee goes you
know the last time we had Brian in
studio and I said no and he goes well it
wasn't officially in studio we're at
Yankee Stadium and so it's Oh for we're
outside your office we're having
Schilling on to talk about Bronson
Arroyo and a rod in the slap and Paulie
goes and knocks on your door to say
would you would you like to come down
and listen to this and then you said
that you didn't want to be on the air
but Paulie goes you might want to listen
to it so Paulie then you come down and
then all of a sudden chill starts
killing a-rod and then I looked at you
and I said you want to talk and then you
go and so we went to commercial break
and came back and you came on talking
about that play with Bronson royal yeah
yeah Paulie I actually have a quote that
you said you said I wonder if she'll he
would say the same thing of trot Nixon
did that to help him win a game yeah I
again I think we talked about an affair
I think my therapist is a great job
erasing from my memory bank anything old
for related so don't go to therapy for
that no no I do it didn't get that bad
now it was
you know it's it's things though I mean
you know what yeah we've had a lot of
success we've had failure you know but
the one when you lose like that at that
sticks with you more than the winning if
that makes any sense it's like it's it's
um enjoy winning as much as they hate
losing
yeah like the winning is a relief it's
like wow thank God and you know that was
awesome is a spectacular but when you
have a situation like we had there in
control I mean that whole series you
know a lot of things happened in it you
know where I don't you know we had an
opportunity from a decision-making
standpoint you know I think you know
shilling we never bunted on when he had
the bad leg they switched catchers
because of a situation remember what why
but their backup catcher was always the
knuckleball receiver can't think of his
name off top my head so but for some
reason Varitek lines up catching yeah
you know they're knuckleballer
way and we won't wait field and that's a
pure opportunity just cuz he couldn't do
it too well so we could have you know
Jackrabbits all over the base path we
chose not to you know we lost all the
word with a Liz Franck fracture on a
check swing and that put our backup Tony
Clark in the game and so there's a lot
of things that happen that you know
losers talk about and we lost the series
and do you really think Schilling had
the bloody sock yeah I mean I there's no
reason not to believe it you know I mean
he had surgery and all that's done I
don't know see Satan O'Connor over there
still doesn't buy into that and it's not
around anymore it's thrown in three I
don't follow the red sock lore we know
for so I just the whole situation was
something that you know again we're up
three games to none and and and this is
I tell you in sports that you know no
matter what the ringer you were in high
school college Pro you know a little bit
probably set in at our fault where you
know the third win of the four-game
series that we had you know the
seven-game series we had but first
before we we closed at Game three in
Fenway and crushed him I know it was
seventeen to three or six or so I mean
it was a blowout and I think maybe an
RSP players were Congrats
our players in pregame in Game four and
you know they're casting like hey man
good luck in the World Series it's true
right yes there's people that make oh
there is no way Red Sox fans go there's
no way I said I saw them and even talked
to one of the Yankees who said they just
said congratulations yeah they're like
dude good luck in the postseason and you
know in the World Series and this and
the other thing and it turns out they're
doing shots before every game as a you
know you know I guess rallying cry
whatever it took it happened the series
started to change and things that's why
you know things can change on a dime
whether it's the last quarter and you're
up and somebody you know you got to
close things out and we didn't and for
whatever the reasons but that again
lessons learned I guess and hopefully if
we're ever in a situation like that
again we will handle it even better than
we did
how good did you think Gary Sanchez was
going to be well we thought he was gonna
be you know a middle lineup he projects
to be a middle on a bat with you know
great defense so we think he can be an
impact you know middle of the order bat
for a long time so we you know I gave
him three million dollars I think was
back in 2009 which is a record bonus at
the time and and for good reason and and
he's honored that you know as he's grown
through the system and he's hungry to be
a great player which there's a lot of
people that have talent but when you
match the hunger to be great with the
talent that's where the magic happens
and I think you know we have a chance to
have a special player enhance your
favorite Steinbrenner story well if it's
a favorite or not I mean there's a lot
but you know when I when I haven't heard
I mean one I'd throw out there is more
of he had he had drivers you know that
he loaned out one day to dignitaries or
family would have you and somehow you
know when I was low hanging fruit I drew
a short straw Kentucky boy in New York
City and they're like you're gonna have
to drive the boss downtown to get a
haircut and I might have been an intern
what can go wrong and then after his
haircut on the east side get him over to
Teterboro and he's gonna fly back to
Tampa and so I had a guy in the office
Peter Jamison was our assistant GM at
the time and he and and it was like oh
my god you can't have to drive the boss
or you know we're how you gonna take him
and I was like well to get him on the
FDR and you know just dig into the FDR
and that's
he did no GPS back then no no no and no
cell phones and he had this a long time
ago and so all of a sudden he goes I got
a quicker way for you so he tells me get
on the deed and go to also Avenue Bridge
and and he gives me this whole new way
and so I get in the car boss gets in the
backseat I get on the Deegan and instead
of going straight to the FDR I start
pulling off in the Willis Avenue Bridge
exit and you ride away he says in the
backseat
he's like hey where you going and I said
I got a quicker way he goes oh okay
we'll see so I take the Brit and anybody
who lives in this area there's a
McDonald's in the corner to this day and
I make the right and the bridge is
closed to completely shut down
I mean it's under construction and it's
a all backed up and he starts railing at
me from the backseat
I mean it's loud and as you could
possibly get me the blank out of here
take me to the blanking subway turn back
get me back to Yankee Stadium you banky
banquet I mean he's killing as loud as I
mean I'm sitting there getting blown up
from the front and try driving under
those I mean the toughest job I think I
might have we've all worked for the
Yankees thought was the driver and there
was always a story about a driver
leaving a guy leaving him on the bridge
because he would go you know intense the
tyrant sometimes tirade sometimes so
anyway so I tuned him out I did the back
up turned around got back on the big
into the FDR and then I hit a pothole
this was back during the Dickens merry
years with a whole bunch of holes
everything and and so he's like this
isn't a blanking tank you know he's just
killing me the entire drive down to the
east side so I get him
you know I tuned him out I didn't engage
I just took the beating the verbal
beating got him to the Upper East Side
and something's like well this may be
why he respected you you just still did
the job under duress and and I got him
to his place and then he chose to take a
cab to but I had some self-worth of
accomplishment I guess because I got him
there under tough circumstances but I
didn't like driving them I don't know if
you have the connections to do this but
maybe Satan O'Connor
could be a bad boy for a Yankee game I
mean is he too old to be a bad boy they
last 38 year old yeah
if I make him shave he's gonna look like
a team he'd have to shave I don't know I
mean that first of all I don't even know
if I can trust a red sock in a Yankee in
a Yankee because how do I know he's
gonna be do what if Matt what if he
dedicate what district clears his love
for the Yankees right now maybe we can
make that happen I can't believe it was
ever even a question raise your right
hand tattoo I think it says Varitek Oh
for thing it's not that's actually a
special date in my life not it's not
baseball related actually thanks for
coming in Brian we appreciate stories
great congratulations congratulations
been a great great season surprising
season well maybe it's surprising to us
maybe not to you but thank you for
coming in he's Brian Cashman the Yankees
senior vice president general manager
and if he offers to give you a ride
don't take it the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience